ah so now we are officially recording
Ashe Sevilla so right now I am here with
Aneta Lucero and I am here to have a
quick one-minute conversation about her
book tell us what it's about Aneta well
that's actually a interesting question
because I don't know that it's about
anything this is a collection of my
thoughts and stories and vignettes and
things that have happened in my life in
my philosophical way of approaching
tragedy and triumph and everything in
between
and I I don't even recall writing this
book it kind of wrote itself I just
started collecting things that I was
posting and saying and stories that I
had written in my blog and and then I
had a magical thing happen where a
publisher just flat-out landed in my lap
I didn't know how to get a publisher or
how to do anything and it just all came
together and he said send me everything
that you've ever written and I sent him
a half done autobiography and just these
musings and some other things and he
said ah that's the ticket right there
these these musics are something and he
helped me organize it and put it
together and um I even enjoy reading it
even though I know all of the stories
and I've read them over and over again
as I've been writing them well what
would you hope people like get out of
this book you know when they pick it up
when they read it what we're what it's a
couple things second I think that the
thing that is most poignant about the
book is that you realize that nobody's
special and everybody's special we can
get on a kick of thinking like oh you
know people tell me all the time oh
you're so special oh you're my role
model or whatever but if you read the
stories in the book and and find where
I'm coming from I've had such a struggle
my entire life but trying to even
believe that I was worthy of living and
you don't know what others are are
feeling at any time and you may think
that somebody has Fame or celebrity or
they've got it all together
and there is no getting it all together
there's you're not you're not alone if
you think that you're not making it or
you have to make it to find something
better in life there is no making it
there's only making it and there is no
making it it's explicit contrast it's a
constant tug-of-war and I think in this
book you see that I I find that I find
that there is no one cider or other I
find that there's only ever something in
the middle and the thing that you find
in the middle is yourself which there is
no self hmm Wow but the stories are
funny and heartbreaking and wonderful
and um they're just whatever I think
this little meat costume me is or isn't
cool well at this point you can go on
Amazon and literally just type in the
towel winning and just as a side benefit
you could also use Amazon smile and
support your favorite charity I would
say the international jugglers
Association or fund the floors but yeah
you can go buy this on Amazon we're
going to transition from this point to a
conversation that you would have to be
one of my patreon subscribers give me a
dollar basically someone you can watch
it and I go by the book
yes not one yet yeah okay so let's start
it up I've just kind of chilled back I
have some questions for you that I've
kind of been writing down here so the
first thing I was just like what would
you want people like you know you're
already a sort of a living legend you
I'm maybe you know this already but you
have revolutionized your own field
you're probably revolutionized other
fields that don't even know about
including being a mother and being a
baton twirler and an artist and costumes
I'm assuming and so what would you want
people to like when you pass or when
you're your time to stop spinning our
twirling is over what would you want
people to remember about you I don't
think it's important to remember
anything about
okay.i I hope that the me that is left
an imprint in specific areas it has been
helpful and positive and whether or not
I remember it is completely
insignificant to me no do you get
validation from being this legend these
days like does it make you just - it
used to be my entire identity and and
what was so funny when it was necessary
for it to be my identity I felt um I
felt like I was never receiving my do
share you know and I feel like a lot of
artists have had this specific quality
to us that we feel like the underdog I
can only speak for myself so let me
change this to me
I felt like the underdog I felt like no
matter what I was inventing or creating
um I wasn't getting enough credit for it
you know it was there was a lot of
credit issues that I lived my life being
disappointed by I had a lot of hardship
just in life and although I always had
within me this is knowing that I was
only competing against myself I had a
lot of good and sustainable qualities
within my own personality but they were
covered by trauma and covered by the way
that I reacted because of that trauma
and covered by blame and my mom did this
to me and the coat you know the judges
who didn't see that and scored me too
low like I could win the world
championships with nearly straight tens
and a couple 9.9 and I was absolutely
devastated and furious that those judges
gave me the 9.9 like was looking at the
wrong side of things for my own
well-being and my own peace hmm was
there a time with that shifted when did
you think when do you think that like
self validating feeling underappreciated
artist side of you shifted to I don't
know what there would be the more the
present-day to modern Aneta when I
realized that my son was going to die
long before me and then everything kind
of came into perspective and the trivial
things in life really revealed
themselves to me as trivial and I didn't
know there was anything wrong with my
son until he was around two years old
and when we got the diagnosis I'm not
one to leave in diagnosis because I
myself have been diagnosed terminal ill
since since birth and was never supposed
to live past 16 so all of those things
were you know when I first heard about
my son is like oh he's just like me it's
it's going to be fine and as time went
on and I realized well it is going to be
fine but fine doesn't necessarily mean
what I had made it to mean in my own
head fine to me always meant that you
beat it you fight against it you push
against it you you win over it you and
in this case all of those ideas in my
life and in my world and in the way that
I had built the foundation of who I
thought I was mm-hmm had to really be
examined because nothing was going to
save save my son didn't need saving
but nothing was going to change the
circumstance hmm that he was severely
terminally ill and he was going to die
and then that was such a gift it was a
gift for me and it was a gift for him
and it was a it was a gift to the world
because I came out a much higher evolved
version of myself and it was a long
process and it's in the process wasn't
finished after my son's to death at 16
um I was you know still pushing still
fighting so and then I was hit by that
car and completely debilitated and
crushed from my shoulders to my pelvis
and suddenly my entire work was done my
it's work was seemingly done and I look
at that it's so trivial yeah I always
remember the time at Sands wedding out
just for inside sake you had just been
in the accident and you came to the
wedding with Noah and I guess it's on
video I don't know if someone's been
seeing it but just one arm contacting I
always remember that and it's just like
a funny moment of yeah seeing you know I
don't really know you super well but
I've seen you at fire drums and I've
known you adjunct Lee because of that
situation but yeah that's amazing
all right I got some other stuff for you
can see yeah so this is kind of a good
question what is the most rewarding like
baton moment of your entire life or one
of the most like what is there like
something like I don't know winning
something particular or oh I'll tell you
the immediate one that stayed with me
for a long time and then I'll tell you
the current one um of course the very
first thing that always comes to my mind
when people ask that are 1983 World
Championships as the youngest senior
woman to ever be placed in that category
the senior woman category my birthday
just comes at a really crummy time for
baton twirling so I was always pushed up
into an older division while I was still
younger than everyone else and and
winning that first World Championships I
had worked and sacrificed my entire
childhood and and really that was the
moment for me and I can still feel like
the relief and that is what is so odd
about what I know now that moment for me
was the most poignant moment in my life
up to that time it's what I thought
everything was going to be about that
was going to change everything and it
was the most amazing thing when the
medal went around my neck and the flag
started to raise and by the time the
national anthem was over I had already
lost interest and wondered what I was
going to do next and then this morning
when I woke up and I saw that gold medal
on the side table beside me and I
realized I'm exactly the same
oh I'm not a superstar I'm not I mean it
said that I'm a world
champion but I felt exactly the same
inside I was still a loser in my own
self so that most poignant moment was
for so many reasons poignant first
because it was the most elation I had
ever felt and and the most success and
it was so brief I have win it again and
I had to win it again and I had to win
it again and it never felt as good and
it didn't mean anything
hmmm-hmmm where was this where did this
happen what was enough Milan Italy hmm
the early eighties and it was absolutely
the best twirling moments you know in my
life and it was significant in the baton
twirling world because I was the first
female to receive all those tens and I
was doing tricks that you know were way
ahead of my time and all kinds of
interesting things happened with that
but this this legendary status that have
somehow been carved by my journey hmm
it's just wrought with this human
experience yeah none of its magical it's
all it's all just heavy living and
having moments of glory and realizing
that those are so fleeting and that
rusted piece it pieces the ultimate
wonderful thing so what was the next
moment what was the new moment he said
this is your first moment that you would
say what was the current day hi but I my
parents my current best moment in baton
twirling is waking up and not having the
need or desire to practice awesome Wow
why is that I got to hear more about
this because this is good um because I
don't have anything to prove
I don't have to stay better than
everybody else I don't it's unimportant
it's become unimportant and it's funny
that a 50 year old woman would you know
get to this farm life and then I still
was practicing and like filming stuff
and showing people and part of that was
to help teach the sport and and to pass
on the joy and passion of movement and
and all of that but a lot of it was also
just showing off that I could I can
still do that role series setter than
anything anyone else and that's gone it
seems interesting because in the if
that's happened in the past couple years
or whatever I've noticed that you know
you got this book I don't really have a
reason to buy your shoes but like it
seems like some of these other elements
of your life now that you've taken less
energy to dedicate to the sport itself
to improve your own personal skills
you've been able to open up into a lot
of other potentially business worlds and
my baton is that true or is that I don't
know anything about business at all but
these opportunities are just uh with
ease and grace landing literally in my
way so that I'm tripping over them and
going oh there's that oh I'll go ahead
and jump off that cliff I'll try that
I'll learn about it as I go maybe
somebody will come into my life to help
teach me about that or don't do it for
me
I'm surprised you're not a motivational
speaker over here I mean maybe that's
like I don't know it sounds to me even
looking at this book there's a funny
thing you said that Kevin acts tell his
mentor Tolley Burke and I don't know
this guy but his thing is let it be easy
is sort of his motto where you know
those things are right in front of you
and you just sort of have to like not
decide whether or not you can do it and
so you're standing right in front of it
don't worry about it until you're right
in front of it and it seems like from
what I've read of the book I've only
read though just a little bit I got
yesterday but that it seems like that's
kind of a lot of that is just to kind of
I mean you can make it one way but
that's not necessarily helping or
hurting
but it's sort of getting you forward so
that's really cool yeah I guess my motto
has been um in in the last 10 years or
so he's in grace just allow me to find
ease and grace and to be able to be ease
and grace and I don't know how it's
going to happen but I know it's going to
happen and what's it is doesn't matter
hmm Wow okay I gotta ask this next
question because if I don't someone's
gonna be mad at me so there's this art
contact staff that existed post baton
twirling FHI everything else probably
within the past 10 years or so is sort
of taking this rise and then the flow
community what is that what are your
thoughts I mean because the tricks are
the same their name similar the name
different I mean what are your thoughts
on the flow community versus a baton
community I just you got to ask the
question right so yeah that's a really
interesting question to ask me in
particular because I've actually have
moments of struggling with it and it's
always pretty obvious when I do because
I'll say something that's pretty close
to snidey on the staff this is a new job
that's yeah
stat-page and then I'll have to start
explaining myself and I'm really
explaining myself to myself and the
benefit is that everybody gets to see
this unfold because I'm very raw and I
don't fake [\h__\h] I'm for real what you
see is what you get and if I'm having a
moment where I'm a little bit irritated
because I see once again some trick that
staffers just posted and said I've just
made this up and has anyone ever seen
this before and then that got little
brat inside of me that trained as a kid
and learn that trick when I was five
years old and saw every single 250 of my
friends also do it when they were 5
years old and you know that'll trigger
like a little something in me and I'll
just say Ike yes according to baton
twirling this trick has been around
since 1973 and did it death but then I
look and I see that I see like
why did that trigger that and how rude
of me what a good jerk and I'll go back
and I'll really look at the staff
community from like these new eyes that
I have and I have so much appreciation
because you guys didn't have trainers
and hundreds of years of you know I
don't know inheritance of this sport you
simply picked up a stick inside figuring
out what to do and that's amazing to me
the things particularly at your level
that that you are doing and the fact
that you figured out how to do that it
is phenomenal hmm I had to have people
teach me how to do that in my practice
you know nine to 12 hours a day with
trainer standing there the entire time
and and that there are folks out there
that can just figure it out is amazing
that's a different kind of brain than I
might have do yeah that way where did
you where did the ideas for a lot of the
contact motions ie like months or roles
4d any of that kind of stuff
where did that come from or the lucero
or where is the inspiration for this
coming from even when you were younger
like is it coming from yeah I always
wondered that cuz it's like did you just
make all that you know you know you hear
like somebody's their first person to do
something obviously that person is
standing on something but I always
curious what that was for you when you
were younger for me but on tellings
literally been in my family for about
100 years
oh so I'm coming from an inheritance of
twirling but from my grandmother my mom
my for aunts everybody every female in
my family twirled so it's hard for me to
say like where where it came from I did
not want to be a baton twirler I didn't
like baton twirling I didn't want to
practice I I tried for the first eleven
years to my life
who was forced to do it and roles for me
um I was always drawn to doing roles I
like the feeling of it up there rolling
around I like how tight I can
I just had a knack for it and I couldn't
bust my face open doing roles and since
that was a big you know every twirler
has a bad left knee from so many spins
every twirlers busted their nose broken
their teeth out had goose bump
you know goose eggs all over their head
their whole life it's just something
that goes with it you're gonna get
smashed with that baton but with rolls
you don't get smashed mmm since I had so
many hours that I was required to train
a day the more that I could train on
rolls the more opportunity I had to not
get hurt did you get the creation like
did they just come up randomly or were
you watching stuff I was I was built and
trained to be a machine I learned
everything there was no artistic quality
showing in me until my early teens and
then it all was like a big rush of hmm
and then I became the Aneta lucero that
that people know my foundation was
nothing but technique and nothing but
machinery hmm and then when that came
over me then yes it was like what can I
create that's different I want to be me
I want to be me I don't want to be that
I don't want to do that role I want to
do something more than that and it
wasn't asked competitively it was
competing with myself what can i what
can I create what can I become how can I
make that different how can I get people
to clap for me more yeah huh
that's cold all right so our final
question I won't take too much of your
time I really appreciate your talking
meaning taking time associate you
talking to me I love your videos I'm
always impressed with everything you put
up I just I really can't believe what
you don't it's stunning to me I have a
great respect I wish you would all not
even particularly so I wish overall that
contact staff community could knock off
the ugly hippie dance thing
tell me more open that up all right
footwork and the whole like this thing
unattractive people unattractive go take
some ballet yes get some foundation of
true and practice movement Baptist
movements can still be free-flowing and
artful it's even more beautiful to watch
because there is a structure behind it
that gives a quality of a look so this
whole you know the thing I'm talking
about right no think of contact staffers
and them hunches and the dancing around
with the feet but there's there's no
training behind it if you're going to
spend so much time training to do these
amazing things at the stick equally
train your body and your stick will go
in the right place so much easier it's
really hard to get a good pattern with
those hideous feet and the hunchy hunch
yeah I could say that I learned that
when I first started getting through
Jamie's cuz yeah I'd like you can't do
it unless you do it the way that you're
told because I tried so long and then
Michelle from Vancouver she just laced
me up and she was just really like very
straightforward about like you know
you're not going to do this if you stand
like that it's impossible so you and I
really and you gave me the vertical
thing which helped me so I get this like
a tradition of technique that comes
along with the body training and I
noticed that if contact staffers could
develop some form of technique within
their body they would rise so quickly
and oftentimes when I'm talking to
staffers they're not quite understanding
that they think in some way that that's
going to inhibit their flow what they
don't realize is it's going to enhance
their flow because you won't be tripping
over your own feet anymore and it looks
better to the eye of the doer mmm-hmm
okay wow that's great
alright so my last thing here I guess
which is uh do you have any I mean I
mean I guess I asked you this is it do
you like yeah do you like fire spinning
what survive on that I just figured out
a piece I really like it you don't like
it okay cuz I watch your DVD it it
seemed like there was a point in time
that you were like all about this fire
game you know I was well I was you know
why cuz I just love Noah if he was going
to do all that fire god damn it I'll be
the fire too and I'm also it was a great
paycheck I was in a high level special
events high-level circus where it it
wasn't just the burn session or whatever
but I was getting a significant paycheck
to do that fire and I was automatically
so good at it
there was no road once I learned the
safety elements which were the most
important part of fire training I was
already good to go I didn't need one
single practice session no we'll put the
staff in my hand I was already basically
the best in the world
oh just like oh I did okay I wasn't
afraid of the fires there was no problem
hmm
but dude do I like it no I don't like
the smell of it um I don't like the look
of all of the gypsy costuming yeah I
don't like that particular flare is it's
not my deal and I never I never costumed
as that I costumed in a very like elite
circuit level kind of deal so but I sure
loved the community and I love the
people and I think the fire staff
community when I went to fire drums
there's so many amazing conversations
with super high quality human beings I
think I met more people that could
instantly teach me something about life
that I hadn't thought about in the past
and it opened me up and it brought me
out of a more conservative cutoff way of
thinking even though I thought I was
very open yeah just fire drums was a
significant event for me and I'm really
glad I went I hate camping and I'm not
that into fire okay well that's good to
hear
if they have to chant about it I am so
yeah yeah I guess again you know this is
for this is all going to be kind of a
private interview
just to kind of let you know where we
sign off here because I I've only done
two I actually interviewed Nick loosely
if you know that guy I interviewed him
last week it was pretty amazing and
you're my second so I'm honored so much
for thinking of me I'm honored and I
love the staff community even when I get
ratty bear with me yeah I actually think
there's a lot of people just not not me
I'm actually like this weird like I try
to be nice in general even though I kind
of have like a anyways but I mean I
think a lot of people enjoy the snark
coming out of Haneda cuz it's sort of
like gods
landing on the context eff community to
say something so but uh alright well
thank you and edit for your time here's
this little book please check out her
book on Amazon and yes it's a great book
I hope everybody can learn um how human
we all are
yeah I'm Stan that'd be okay mm-hmm
well it's cool this is like better than
getting the book signed like you're like
right here I'm like look like by Aneta
thank you so so much
take care Aloha bye
do I do this I'm gonna click this thing
here I'll see you later net I'm hanging
up